[Music]
I've always assumed because you seem
like a very confident guy you you seem
like a guy who who would do well with
the ladies
and then today one of our saving
producers showed me a picture of you and
you were on the math team and it's funny
because I'm not holding you in any way I
just didn't think of you as like math
team guy you know that's well let me
tell you something a 1st through 5th
grade not a single girl liked me I was
terribly dyslexic couldn't read till 5th
grade I discovered I had a superpower I
was great at geometry like in 5th grade
and then when I went into 6th grade my
brother pulled me aside he was 5 years
older and he said this year you're gonna
have a side spike hairdo which is that
moto sides fight I heard a that right
outside I got a nice spike on the on the
part right he made me get that haircut
and then I excelled at math this turned
my whole life around that haircut with
blew the minds of the 8th graders the 88
girls didn't know what hit him when they
saw that side spike all of my brother's
doing and then the math team made me
feel confident and I started excelling
at school and without that photo I
wouldn't be sitting here today but you
almost had the same hair as the girl and
the bunny sweatshirt yeah
[Applause]
handy she did very well with she did
very well with women - don't say it
and her older brother also pulled her
aside and I heard that haircut
you